yep like all mathematicians he's tall
blonde and handsome yeah
yeah
well i'm not talking well he's not tall
or blonde or is he
is he that's not tall i don't know i
wasn't down i wasn't counting
i guess um the choice of maths was
arbitrary they wanted to do a film about
a
troubled genius
and the originally they were going to do
physics genius um and then they were
advised
to pick a mathematical genius because it
might seem it might work better with
script
it's a really good film
and
the maths is less important shall we
talk about what they've what they did in
the in the film the maths yeah all right
so we'll talk about that first near the
beginning of the film
um the mit professor sets his students a
challenge who can solve this i'll put it
on the blackboard in the corridor
and who can solve this problem it's
taken it's taken us mit professors two
years to solve this problem
can you do it
now
is it as hard as he made out so what was
the problem if i say it first of all i'm
gonna say the problem that he gave the
students it might sound like greek to
you because some of it is greek right so
then i'll save the problem
then i'll tell you how it works and it's
a problem we can all do at home all
right i promise so the problem is
draw
or
homeomorphically irreducible trees of
size n equals 10.
what does that mean all right let's try
this out these things are called trees
uh so
so trees instead of that where they are
networks of dots and lines
so these are called graphs
it's like it's like the london
underground map
so
a network of dots and lines so this is
called a tree
what's not allowed what is banned
is something like this
okay this is banned this has a cycle in
it and cycles are banned now what was
that other big word i said
homeomorphically that's the worst one
that's actually not so bad that means
if i did this
these two
are the same picture can you see what
i've done i've just moved the dots
slightly so you can rotate them and
reflect them or you could move them
around slightly but those two pictures
would count as the same thing and there
was another clever word
there was the word irreducible in there
so that's another band thing
here this time
what is banned
is
something like this
this
is banned only two lines go into that
dot which means
pretty much nothing happens you go in
and you go out again nothing happens
right there's no change nothing
interesting here
so this is banned as well right those
are the rules
we want to do it for 10 dots this is the
problem will hunting had
10 dots how many ways are there to do it
i can tell you
there are 10 ways to do it
what i thought might be fun is if i did
a couple of them and maybe leave some
for people to try and work out
what
i've left no
i want to see all of them you want to
see all of them
boring right so the first one is wow
so is that so if you can do that in less
than two years then you're better
apparently you're better than mit
professors
or if you prefer
these are all the trees
of size 10 or this is a spider with nine
legs and that's a guy with a funky afro
i don't think that's a particularly hot
i think people can do this at home
but
the problem isn't the important thing um
what i really would like to talk about
is who was the real good will hunting
story as well so
will hunting solves this problem there
is an urban legend that's that's similar
of of a student who ran into his exam
late
and he copied down the problems from the
board and he went and solved them and
the last one seemed really hard but he
kept working on it and he and he managed
to solve it and he handed in his exam
paper
and then the professor rings him that
night saying you're only meant to do the
first few problems the last one was an
unsolvable problem oh you've solved it